MARK STEYN THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WE ARE STILL
AWAITING THE PRESIDENT'S
MOMENT.
JOE HAS BEEN AROUND THESE
ISSUES FOR A LONG TIME.
FORMER DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR
THE DISTRICT OF COLOMBIA.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE.
IT'S TRUE OR NOT IS
THREATENING TO RESIGN.
>> I HOPE HE DOES.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THAT
COMING FROM?
>> CHRIS WRAY PLANTED THESE
STORIES HIMSELF.
FORMER AGENTS THAT HE IS
BRAVE.
HE IS STALL WART.
HE IS STANDING UP FOR THEM.
THIS IS NONSENSICAL.
IF HE OFFERS TO RESIGN, THE
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR BY FBI
DIRECTOR IS CHILDISH.
IT'S IMMATURE.
BEEN SEEKING THE DOCUMENTS
FOUR PAGE MEMORANDUM WHICH
DEMONSTRATE THE CORRUPTION
ON THE SEVENTH FLOOR OF THE
FBI AND AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNDER COMEY.
AND OTHERS.
IT IS INCONCEIVABLE TO ME
THAT WRAY HAS TO TURN TO A
THREAT OF RESIGNATION TO
MAKE HIMSELF LOOK GOOD.
IT DISPLAYS A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP LACK OF
CONFIDENCE AND.
IN ADDITION, IT SHOWS
ARROGANCE TOWARD
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
SAYING, MR. SPEAKER, YOU
REALLY DON'T WANT YOU TO
PUBLISH THIS MEMO.
WHAT IN THE NAME OF GOD IS
WRONG AT THE TOP OF THE FBI?
>> Tucker: I GUESS WHAT I'M
CONFUSED BY.
LIKE MOST AMERICANS I'M
ENFORCEMENT INTEL AGENCIES.
IT'S MY GOVERNMENT.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE.
WHAT MAKE ME NERVOUS AND
EXPLAIN WHY THE COUNTRY
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
DONE A MISERABLE JOB AT
DOING.
WHY THEY CAN'T DO WHAT
PEOPLE WANT THEM TO DO.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT CHRIS WRAY
WAS ARGUING FOR YESTERDAY
AND TODAY?
TO REMOVE THE NAMES OF ALL
THE FBI AGENTS AND THE DOJ
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BROKEN THE
>> Tucker: ON WHAT GROUNDS?
HOW WOULD THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
FROM THE REREDACTION.
WRAY AND ROSENSTEIN.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THE
BUREAUCRACY.
KNOWING ANYTHING.
AND THEY THINK THE COUNTRY
CANNOT SURVIVE WITHOUT THEM.
THIS IS THIS PHONY NOTION
THAT DOJ AND THE FBI ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, IT IS AN
INSIDIOUS CONCEPT.
THEY WORK FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE CAN FIRE THEM.
HE CAN TELL THEM WHAT TO DO.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IS HE
GOING TO INTERFERE IN AN
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THE ARROGANCE OF WRAY
AND ROSENSTEIN DEFY
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
ASK THE SPEAKER TO TAKE OUT
NAMES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BROKEN THE LAW.
HOW OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THE ARGUMENT OF THE TALK
SHOW HOST.
ASK THE QUESTIONS YOU ARE
ASKING DEMONSTRATE THE LACK
OF RESPECT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU DON'T APPRECIATE THE
WORK THEY DO.
THE RISKS THEY TAKE.
WHAT YOUR GOVERNMENT IS
BEEN A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
AND INVESTIGATOR FOR MORE
THAN 30 YEARS.
I HAVE HAD MY FAMILY
THREATENED BY DRUG DEALERS
AND TERRORISTS.
THIS IS NONSENSICAL.
WE ALL RESPECT THE STREET
AGENTS.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS CRITICISM OF
POLITICAL APPOINTEES OF THE
FBI.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE STREET AGENTS.
THE ARGUMENTS OF THE LEFT
ARE PHONY ARGUMENTS DESIGNED
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE PEOPLE,
LIKE ME, WHO ARE CRITICAL OF
THE FBI IN THIS SITUATION
ARE CRITICAL OF EVERYONE
THAT'S NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: WHEN JOAN WALSH
SAYS YOU ARE UNPATRIOTIC FOR
ASKING WHAT YOUR GOVERNMENT
IS DOING YOU SAY IT'S NOT
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> AS AN OLD U.S. ATTORNEY I
DON'T LIKE DIRTY COPS.
THE SEVENTH FLOOR IS FULL OF
THEM AND YOU WERE ECHELON OF
THE DOJ UNDER OBAMA WAS FULL
OF DIRTY COPS.
THEY THREW A CASE AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON LIKE A BUNCH
OF LOUSY 1930S PRIZE
FIGHTERS FOR 500 BUCKS AND
THEY TRY TO FRAME DONALD
TRUMP WITH A CREATED CRIME.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE OUR
PATRIOTIC DUTY WOULD BE TO
UNTANGLE THE MESS, FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED AND --
>> -- LET'S FIND OUT WHAT